about three years ago I became the
national coach of the United States
international math Olympiad team I was
very happy for a day thinking this is
this is this is very interesting but the
next day I started to think that maybe I
should do something with this and I
decided that I wanted to focus not only
on training an elite group of students
but trying to do some as much as I could
to boost the baseline mathematics
capability in this entire country
unfortunately I had no money no
connection and only one person so the
only thing I knew was mathematics
algorithms and this probability and
network theory so after thinking for
some time I actually came to an idea
which was based on using these core
mathematical areas I had been working
with to actually build a solution for
education that could be delivered for
free on every smartphone this is
actually the project I'm working on
right now called XP our principle is
that actually you could turn that
smartphone into a virtual tutor which
automates what a person would get if
they hired a tutor it wouldn't be as
good as a tutor but it could get very
close and if you could deliver a free
almost tutor on every smartphone in the
United States you might solve equity
problems you might be able to allow
everyone even if they lived in a
different zip code to be able to access
this tutor which previously had only
been accessible to people who are quite
wealthy because today the cost of a
tutor is in the thirty dollars an hour
20 dollars an hour fifty dollars an hour
depending on how you look at it if you
can reduce that to zero dollars an hour
you would actually open up this
accessibility to everyone if we realize
that what we're trying to build is this
virtual tutor then you actually again
can start to conceptualize well
knowledge happens to be all of these
concepts linked together in this network
then the problem becomes if you have
this network how do you mathematically
analyze where a person should go next
that can be done by using probability
and statistics to find new ways to
measure how much each person understands
about each concept statistics because
the way that one would measure this is
by asking them questions the experience
someone has is they indicate what they
want to learn and then the system starts
to pitch questions at them questions
that they would need to know how to
answer
in order to understand what they claim
they want to understand as the questions
come based on people's responses to the
questions the system adjusts the
difficulty of the question and where the
next questions come from in the same way
that a human tutor adjust their line of
questioning based on whether a person is
successful or not successful at the
previous question if the student reaches
a point where they are hopelessly
confused meaning they don't know how to
do this question at all then the system
suggests that maybe they could read some
explanations as you can see it turns the
lesson flow upside down it's not that
the class comes first and then the
homework and then the exam the first
thing that comes is the exam essentially
followed by these practice problems
which adapt to you followed by the class
for anything that you don't know the
idea is that this should cure boredom at
the high end and also cure confusion at
the struggling end I actually started
this with a brilliant Carnegie Mellon
undergraduate student and I'm the two of
us built this system together but when
when you start with no resources you
need to think of ways to actually
generate all of this content in a way
which doesn't cost an enormous amount of
resources and we took inspiration from
Wikipedia our system aggregates all of
the questions and explanations that
anyone in the world might want to
contribute users voting like a website
called Quora
in order to find out which content is
strong and uses statistics these and the
algorithms to figure out what questions
are easy and difficult so actually in
the end it turns out that it sucks in
all of this content it licenses it all
with the Creative Commons license like
Wikipedia and then puts it all across on
a platform that anyone with a smartphone
can use as we keep developing these
mathematics and algorithms our goal is
actually to deliver free education to
all of the world using a system that
self-organizes in the same way that
mathematics self-organizes from its
basic assumptions
[Music]